Hey how you feeling?
>> So much better.
>> Yeah, it really looks like
you're getting a lot done.
>> I think he's in the zone now.
>> Yeah,
I think we should leave him alone.
>> Yeah.
>> Well, anyway, we just scratched
the surface of code editors.
But now you know it's out there.
And just like everybody's different and
has their own way of doing things,
it's the same with code.
>> That's right.
You should go out and
experiment with different code packages,
keyboard shortcuts,
maybe even try a new code editor.
You'd be surprised at
how fun it can be and
how easy it is to improve
your workflow that way.
>> Yeah, you'll have a chance
to practice in the next lesson.
You're going to dive deeper into
the layout and sizing of elements.
I'll see you there.